على بعد نحو ثمانين كيلومترا عن الحدود
الغربيه للصومال يقع واحد من اكبر مخيمات
اللاجئين في افريقيا مخيم دادا شمس عبد
الرشيد محمد واطفالها السته اتوا الى
المخيم طلبا للمساعده قطعت شمس مسافه 500
كيلومتر سيرا وهي حامل من قريتها في جنوب
الصومال الى دادا
عندما وصلنا لم نحصل على بطاقه معاونات
غذائيه لمده ثلاثه اشهر تقريبا لم يكن
لدينا ماء او ماوى او طعام ساعدنا بعض
اللاجئين باعطائنا الطعام وفي الشهر
الرابع حصلنا على البطاقه واعطونا بعض
الذره
يهز اوغاش ادم عبد الله وعاء شبه فارغ الا
من كميه قليله من بذور الذره فهي كل ما
تبقى من قوت لمده عشره ايام اخرى لهذا
اللاجئ الصومالي وعائلته المكونه من 13
فردا في دادا
عندما نحصل على حصتنا الغذائيه نبيع بعضها
لشراء السكر والاشياء الضروريه الاخرى
لذلك ليس لدينا ما يكفي من الطعام حتى
التوزيع المقبل
يصل ما بين
4500 شخص يوميا غالبيتهم العظمى من
الصوماليين الى المخيم الذي يعوي اصلا
350 الف شخص فر معظمهم من الجفاف التاريخي
الذي يضرب الصومال
عندما نفقت جميع ماشيتنا قررنا القدوم الى
مخيم اللاجئين هذا في كينيا استغرق الامر
منا نحو 20 يوما للوصول الى هنا يضم تذاب
ثلاثه مخيمات مكتظه عن اخرها وعلى وشك
الانهيار
[موسيقى]
تنظم عمليات توزيع المياه في المخيمات
منظمه اطباء بلا حدود التي تدير ايضا
مركزا صحيا للاجئين الواصلين اخيرا
مما اتلقاه من اخبار هذا هو اسوا ما
رايناه على الاطلاق اذا ما قارنا الوضع
بعام 2011 عندما كان لدينا مثل هذا التدفق
على الرغم من التدفق الكبير للاجئين على
المخيمات فان التمويل لا يتدفق بالمستوى
نفسه ومن المقرر فتح مخيم رابع في الاشهر
المقبله لاستيعاب ثمانين الفا من الوافدين
الجدد ويحتاج المخيم الى نحو 23 مليون
دولار لم تتلقى الامم المتحده منها سوى
خمسه ملايينها حتى الان